this question here doesn't tell you hey
um like they will say solve that will be
the actual wording of the question then
we just say here's an inequality and
they'll just say solve it and it's a bit
funny you might think like what does
this why does this belong in the top it
called graphing techniques like it
hasn't asked me to graph okay the reason
why it's in this topic is because like
far and away the best way to solve this
is actually by graphing yeah um there
are ways to solve without graphing and
they suck I think they can be long
they're confusing you get an answer and
you're like is it right it's highly
unreliable okay so what we're gonna do
is like our mechanism for this is um is
two steps okay number one we're gonna
we're going to create a graph of the
left-hand side of this inequality
okay that X cubed plus 5x squared plus
6x we're gonna get a picture of that and
then the second thing is will interpret
that graph on the basis of this
inequality okay and they're two quite
separate steps okay so let's have a go
at step one that thing on the left hand
side if I just took that and I said let
y equal to that okay
let's try our best to work out what this
thing looks like okay when you graph
it's always helpful like in our previous
questions to factorize so can you tell
me are there any common factors here at
these three terms yeah I can just take
an X out of the whole thing so let's do
that put an X out the front what does
that leave you with inside the brackets
okay now once you've taken out that X
the thing inside the brackets is a
quadratic so you can factorize again can
you help me work out I'm looking for a
pair of numbers yeah the partners right
they add two starts are very misleading
on three very good so two and three will
add to five they'll multiply to 6 so
I'll get this okay
now wonder if you can remember what's
the point of factorizing why does
factorizing help us graph perfect
exactly so um which intercepts by the
way because
yeah perfect wonderful so we factorized
in X so you get X intercepts okay so
that's a lot of information why don't we
start to draw a set of axes and we start
to start to get a sense of what this
thing looks like okay I'm gonna cheat a
little bit and draw some straight lines
here sorry I know it's not fair um do
you have a ruler on you by the way yeah
I will say like yes especially when like
you know if you're using your graph as
part of you're working for the answer
you're like my grass gotta be decent
enough to say hey look is my look is my
look at my name working right okay so um
we've got a good enough set of axes to
work on here I'm going to take the
information we just got and put it onto
my graph yeah so I've got an intercept
at x equals zero is what you told me I
want to have a decent scale on this so
I'm gonna go negative one there's
negative two and then I go one more over
that's negative three okay so I'll go
ahead and I will just label those points
zero to move it over with negative 2 and
then negative three okay cool I've got X
intercepts I feel like I should get y
intercepts
how do I find y innocence then y equals
in that x equals y very good so if I let
X equal zero I often say to find y
intercepts just so I don't get confused
to find y and it says I'll let X equal
zero what do you get out of Y yeah
you're fine take your time
that's okay that's right I I sort of
raced ahead okay um have a look at our
equation for y yeah the original one
right when you put x equals zero into
this guy what happens you're getting a
whole bunch of zeros right like was here
wait a second I already found the
y-intercept because I possibly the
origin right do you like Jake's already
found okay now that that actually
happens quite frequently on the sites no
III was wondering see a question but it
is worth noting like if you don't pass
through your
you're gonna pass through the y-axis
somewhere else so you still have to go
through that process so I thought it was
worth just making sure okay good now
you're like uh what is that it like I
feel like I need more information about
this right it's a polynomial polynomials
don't have asymptotes so many times
there's no breaks in the graph so I need
to work out it's gonna be there's gonna
be a smooth curve that goes through this
but I don't know how to yeah it's gonna
where it's gonna wiggle around okay so
one of the things that will help with
all kinds of graphs whether they are
polynomials like this or those rational
functions or Exponential's is I want to
work out what's happening on the left
hand side and the right hand side of the
graph right so if I put in say for
example like some ridiculously large
negative number okay like say a negative
100 right well why would I do that in
the answer is I want to know what's
going on like this shows me what's
happening in the middle but I want to
know what's happening on either side of
that okay so x equals negative hundred
is very far in that direction okay now
you've got a calculator there I can see
I wonder if you can put into your
calculator subcision negative 100 cubed
plus five lots of negative hundred
squared and just be careful with when
you input this because let me just
actually put some work in here when x
equals negative a hundred y is going to
equal negative 100 cubed plus five lots
of negative 100 squared and I just want
you to be cautious with your brackets
because if you put the minus sign in the
wrong spot the calculator will think you
mean something else right so when you
put that in what do you get okay just
really to just move it that's a lot of
notice okay see you're like wait a
second some huge negative number right
which is to say like x equals maybe 100
is to the left
y equals negative nine hundred fifty
thousand six hundred is like rock bottom
right it's a very very large negative
value okay now I think you can see
without even testing it if I make X
equal positive 100
it's just gonna be some huge value right
like something big okay because you're
like oh I'm gonna cube a hundred yeah
and then I'm gonna square a hundred like
it's just gonna get massive right so
it's gonna be very me so in other words
what we're getting is on the left hand
side which is negative x you get very
low values very negative values of Y and
then on the right hand side you get very
positive values did you see that yeah
now why are these are helpful to me is
I'm like oh I have to yeah I have to
come from the left down the bottom and
eventually I've got to go to the right
at the top okay and then I've got to
meet these three points in the middle
all right so what's this going to look
like well I've got to come up to that
that intercept over there right see that
I've got to come up to meet the
intercept now you don't need to draw
this because gonna be wrong but clearly
I can't just keep on marching up right
I've got to come back down to the
intercept we have length we have
calculus language for this right what is
there going to be between negative three
and negative two
it's got to it's got to turn around
right so it's a turning point okay so
there's a turning point I drew that
really badly so there's a turning point
right there this question didn't ask us
where that turning point was so I'm not
going to find it okay now just like
before I can't just keep on going down
here I've got to come back up so there's
another turning point right so it turns
back up towards zero okay and then where
am I going to end up yeah I've got to go
meet that spot on the right-hand side
actually I have no idea where I'm
actually gonna my lines gonna go
something like that yeah okay and that's
the graph okay
now I will point out I'm looking at
yours and mine one of the differences
between yours and mine is like it's
they're very similar but I want you to
look closely at the very left hand side
and the very right hand side yeah your
graphs kind of level off they kind of
become like straight lines which they
are not oh you remember how we got this
like ridiculously negative number here
so it really is very steep okay so
that's why you can see mine gets steeper
and steeper forever you gotta watch out
for that because remember how I said
shape really matters yeah all right
take a breath remember I said there's
two big steps to this number one no I
approach you've actually done the hard
one okay number one was graph we've done
that okay that's why it's in this topic
number two we need to interpret this
right you're like I've got a graph but
what does it mean okay so come back to
the original question here's the
original question up here right you've
got this graph which we've just done
yeah and then the rest of the question
which we just kind of ignored up to this
point is is lesser than 0
now for graphs what that means is when
are you below the axis okay that graph
that we just true when is it when is it
underneath okay now I hope you can see
there's two parts of this graph that are
underneath
yeah can you highlight them for me what
are those parts yeah yeah the beginning
part right here on the left and this
little this little middle bump here
right do you read that
okay now those they're two sections I'm
after what I need is the X values that
give me those two spots let me say it
again in fact it's worth writing what I
want is the solution is what X values
what X values correspond to those two
sections right correspond to these parts
of the graph what exercise correspond to
these parts of the graph okay
so have a look um looking at the graph
you know you the first thing you said
was oh it's the the beginning part right
so it's like everywhere over here
everywhere over here is is for excise is
good at what point do I start what
exercise at the three right there
negative three very good so everything
to the left of negative three is fine
does that make sense yeah so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna say there's
negative three and then I go all the way
to the left like so so that's X is less
than negative three
like so okay so those are the x-values
that give you that that part over there
I also need expose that give me that
middle section what are the expose that
sort of fence that in zero right and
then I want between those two spots so
in here like so so I would say negative
2 is less than X which is less than zero
case you start for negative two and then
you go all the way up to zero okay now
that right there in green the the first
one or the second one that's the answer
that's the inequalities solution okay
now I will just say and this is calling
a very very old knowledge so if you
can't remember it I'll help you that's
how you would write the answer in
inequality notation do you remember
there was this thing called interval
notation that we learn like very early
last yeah it's in a while ago okay
so it's a bit sneaky so I'm just gonna
remind you what it looks like it takes
these same numbers right yeah there's
like brackets and stuff like that so
what we would say is on the left hand
side where do you start from and the
answer is from negative infinity and
then going from the left where do you
stop we already said this value negative
three right like so okay and then you
you then say okay well then I have
another one and it's from negative 2 all
the way to zero
right and then we would say the word for
the symbol for or is this are you
looking simple here which means which
means Union okay